muy buenos días pues estamos hoy en el
día 13 de este juicio que comenzó el
pasado 8 de septiembre y por las
próximas cinco semanas pues como usted
bien lo decía se van a escuchar los
testimonios de cerca de 300 personas
entre sobrevivientes pero también de
familias que perdieron a sus seres
queridos durante esa fatídica noche del
13 de noviembre de 2015 300 personas
prácticamente serán escuchadas ante la
justicia se espera que a partir de hoy y
mañana pues se escuchan los testimonios
de las personas que estuvieron presentes
en el estadio de francia y luego será
también toda esta semana de las personas
que estuvieron en las diferentes
terrazas de los restaurantes de los
barrios 10 y 11 donde allí también pues
hubo una parte de estos atentados y
luego las siguientes cuatro semanas pues
serán para las personas que estuvieron
presentes allí en la sala de el bataclán
son momentos bastante difíciles estos
importantes dos maneras estos
testimonios porque le da una una cara a
las víctimas a ese dolor ahora forma
parte también de la reconstrucción de
todas estas personas de para y seguir
adelante con sus vidas pero son momentos
también muy dolorosos hace pocos
instantes había una mujer que ya estaba
dentro de la sala de audiencia y al ver
a las 14 personas que están allí a los
acusados pues se rompió en llanto y
finalmente tuvo que ser atendida por
personas que están allí para dar apoyo
psicológico a las familias de todos los
presentes así que son momentos bastante
difíciles muchas personas que no quieren
hablar con la prensa de hecho al
interior a cada una de las personas que
está allí para dar su testimonio a cada
una de estas personas presentes pues
ellas tienen un cordón ya sea verde un
rojo verde cuando desean hablar con la
prensa y rojo cuando no desean hacerlo o
incluso pueden tener los dos en caso de
que en algún momento quieran cambiar de
parecer y quieran de alguna manera pues
dar a conocer a su testimonio de algunas
palabras a la prensa